aujourd'hui pour lancer la saison une
entrevue avec notre ancien animateur
yvon leblanc
pendant 24 ans il a été le visage de la
semaine verte
nombreux sont ceux qui se souviennent
d'ailleurs de son chapeau et sa belle
voix grave
voici donc quelques moments de cet
entretien avec un clin d'oeil à cette
musique qui a marqué notre mémoire
collective
[Musique]
ils vont leblanc participent pendant
plusieurs années à la semaine verte
comme narrateur et c'est en 1978 qu'il
arrive à la barre de l'émission
j'arrivais de l'information et puis le
magazine à la fois locaux nationaux et
puis j'ai même touché un peu l'actualité
internationale
mais je connais ses strictes omarienne
d'agriculture je m'y étais intéressé
pendant les années qui ont précédé à
partir de 71 72
le mouvement de protection de
l'environnement et eni mais j'avais
beaucoup à apprendre
la controverse entourant la fin de
l'année à terre-neuve est de nouveau
relancé jeu maintenant offrir à se
pomponner sa friandise préférée
picotin d'avoine vraiment que certains
courent encore les érables avec cheval
et paris
d'autres contrôles la coulée devant leur
ordinateur dès le début ce chasseur
amoureux de la nature qui ne vient
pourtant pas du milieu agricole est
séduit par cette nouvelle émission
merci d'avoir choisi de me laisser
entrer chez vous pendant temps dimanche
si longtemps c'était un privilège au
plaisir
merci de votre fidélité en somme et
conserver une houle à cette émission ne
méritait peut-être plus que jamais
nécessaire merci pour la confiance donc
bonne continuation et qui sait au revoir
je me suis dit ben voila voila magazine
qui s'occupe de la terre de la mer et
des foires et l'essentiel de
l'environnement voilà donc un peu le
magazine dont je rêvais dont je rêvais
l'existence elle était déjà là d'après
moi largement en germe et ça s'est
précisé ça s'est accentué la
préoccupation environnementale a été
intégré ensuite par le groupe de
grenoble qui dirigeait un peu l'émission
y'a eu ouverture totale et 50 ans plus
tard vous êtes là
à parler un peu des mêmes sujets mais
avec quelques inquiétudes et quelques
nuages de plus l'horizon
pendant près d'un quart de siècle il est
aux premières loges
alors que la foresterie les pêcheries et
l'agriculture vivent des transformations
majeures ce que juste surtout observer
c'est l effort considérable les succès
obtenus dans les rendements
c'était dans les trois domaines la
course au rendement qui semblait dont on
sent d'être plus fiers et qu'on
illustrait chaque semaine avec
différents reportages
la machinerie toujours plus performante
permet à la productivité de faire des
gains impressionnants
[Musique]
ce que j'ai observé avec une certaine
inquiétude comme bien des gens c'étaient
les cussac où les essoufflements de
certaines orientations est vraiment qui
s'accumulait au tour de ceux de ce
rendement dont on était très fier
pendant plusieurs années il devra lutter
même au sein de l'émission pour rendre
compte de cette nouvelle réalité
la trace importante était donné au
secret story alors on discutait pas trop
on ne regardait pas nécessairement les
effets secondaires si je peux dire que
certain c'est que ce soit on montrait
surtout avec fierté qu'on est assorti de
la survivance d'une certaine pauvreté
il observe alors que cette évolution
saluée de tous fait toutefois naître un
certain malaise une sorte de gêne
s'installe est carrément dans le milieu
tranquillement plutôt à propos des
inconvénients que ça fait peut-être
apporter des critiques plus ça peut
peut-être soulevez vous pensez à quoi
l'agriculteur empoisonneurs par exemple
qui on pouvait reprocher un usage
excessif de pesticide en forêt le
secteur phare ici s'est sentie aussi
très interpellé par l'ampleur des co
dans les années 90 une nouvelle
orientation et donner à l'agriculture
elle doit se tourner vers l'exportation
une tangente qui encore aujourd'hui
laisse l'ancien animateur perplexe on
mesure le succès économique d'un pays
ses exportations et l'agriculture en est
une preuve
mais si les coûts environnementaux qui
sont pas pris en compte en ont mais ça
comme la dette aux prochaines
générations
c'est ma part et pour une politique très
saine à long terme c'est pas durable
en tout cas aujourd'hui âgé de 77 ans
yvon leblanc maintient toujours un
regard critique sur les sujets qu'il a
si longtemps couvert mais ils se
laissent aussi émouvoir
je pense que la vie est extrêmement
émouvant notamment à cause de sa
fragilité sa tête le mouvement du vivant
dans quelques brindilles comme comme
actuellement ce qui m'émeut aussi de
façon un peu négative c'est quand c'est
quand on sent que que pour certains la
nature n'est que une potentialité une
occasion de s'enrichir
et comme si on oubliait qu'il est
essentiel au maintien de la vie
je trouve qu'on a on a une
responsabilité quant à notre propre
espèce de lui assurer une sorte d'
environnement cadre de vie qu'ils soient
le moins dégradée possible et sur cette
question la berre le magazine national
verte exerce une sorte de surveillance
qui m'apparaît très nécessaire qu'est ce
que vous auriez comme message pour des
jeunes qui se lancent en agriculture
c'est un sacré beau métier que celui de
nourrir avec responsabilité que nourrir
des êtres humains
les efforts de type de vie que ça
représente
il n'ya pas pts et du travail en
agriculture et enfin reste je leur dirai
bravo et j'espère que vous allez en
vivre avec avec orgueil et suffisamment
[Musique]